but can we can we talk about biden's
mental state to go back to this neurons
firing thing
i've been wanting to talk about his
mental state for a while yes well
well now you get to from uh this is from
al.com
biden confuses tuskegee airmen with
syphilis
study victims in explaining covet
vaccine reluctance
what this is the perfect storm of
of biden's brain just breaking on tv
because not only were people like yo
that's like really racist for more than
one reason
he was like saying that latinx people
and minorities
yeah yeah don't want to get vaccinated
because they're scared and he's like
remember the tuskegee airmen and it's
like ah dude
okay okay okay let's slow down for a
minute the tuskegee airmen are heroes
there was didn't trump present an award
to one like a couple years ago oh yeah
recently he like stood up and then like
everyone was cheering for this guy
they're they're they're they're amazing
heroes
the tuskegee syphilis experiments were
horrifying acts where the government
basically told people
they were being treated for their
disease but they were just being watched
die the gov like these these are people
who could have been treated the guy was
like yeah but we want to see what
happens if we don't treat them so
we'll just keep giving them placebos
that that
yeah joe biden joe biden ladies and
gentlemen here's bobby there's a storm
tom check it out check this out let me
read a little bit okay okay
joe biden is drawing criticism for
comments he made that mixed up tuskegee
airmen
a heroic group of african-american world
war ii pilots
with victims of an infamous alabama
syphilis
study speaking on the reluctance of some
people to get coveted 19
vaccines biden said it was harder to get
african-americans initially vaccinated
because it it used to be that they
experimented on them
the tuskegee airmen and others i just i
just want to say like
all right look i understand biden's not
all with it
my bigger concern is if remember when he
was doing the thing at the g7 where he
said
libya instead of syria over and over
again could you imagine if he's like
sitting there in front of putin
and he's like you want the sanctions
lifted you got to get out of libya
and putin goes okay okay
[Music]
and then like syria blows up you know
whatever that's the problem with him not
speaking properly now in this instance
it's more of a face palm where he
literally accused these heroic world war
ii pilots
of being syphilitic men who are used by
the government in an experiment
it's gonna people are gonna think it's
true now too for for their whole lives
oh yeah yup yup there are a lot of
people this is the crazy thing who they
heard him say it and and it's like we
were just talking about the media yes
that when the when the when the nyc
election thing happens and this guy eric
adam's legit like hey this looks wrong
the media attacks him like crazy how
many people heard biden say that and
they're like that's right the tuskegee
airmen had syphilis
i think this is more like the mandela
effect we were talking about last night
because now he's
interjected this idea he skipped
timelines it really was the tuskegee
airman
biden actually is the only one that
knows he's
in the dimensional shift it's going to
be like 30 years and someone's going to
be like on a podcast which is like
virtual reality or something
like don't you remember that experiment
with tuskegee airmen where they were
given syphilis
and they're like yeah i remember that it
never happened
according to snopes.com it was actually
a cdc experiment whoa
dude i remember though dude my great
grandfather served in the tuscany
my
syphilis is an std right like these
these are so the the study was like
people who got
the std went to get treatment and the
government was like yeah we're gonna
give you free health care and then
didn't
treat them and just let them slowly die
like it's
kind of dishon i'm not trying to rag on
people who contract illnesses or
anything like that but like
to look at this photo of these like
heroic world war ii pilots
and then joe biden to accidentally say
they all had syphilis yeah
that's like a brutal thing to say about
these guys
he owes their family some reparations
yeah i agree
reparations that's fair david e martin
in a talk he gave at the free and brave
conference gets into
it gets into the actual story with the
with the right you know tuskegee
experiment
so well so i i have it this is
interesting i just pulled it from the
cdc.gov
and what they say what they say about it
and we were just before the show i had
pulled up the original reporting which
they have here as well
they say in 1932 the u.s public health
service
with the tuskegee institute began a
study to record the natural history of
syphilis
they say the study initially involved
600 black men 399 with syphilis 201 who
did not have the disease
participants informed consent was not
collected
researchers told the men they were being
treated for bad blood
a local term to describe several
ailments including syphilis anemia
fatigue in exchange for taking part in
the study the men received free medical
exams free meals
and burial insurance think about that
they're like yeah we'll we'll take care
of you sure and then like we'll pay for
it when you die
they mentioned that in 1943 penicillin
was a treatment of choice for syphilis
becoming widely available but that but
the participants
were not offered treatment the us
government knew
they could save the lives of these men
but the cdc and the u.s
public health service were like let's
watch them die and see what we can you
know we'll write it down
definitely garnered a lot of data i'm
sure
and you know david e martin who i was
just mentioning did say that the cdc
and i haven't actually gone to verify
this but apparently started with
studying why malaria kills some people
and not others
it's really like trying to understand
plagues
you know which which makes sense for the
the greater story of the cdc
but it is it is kind of interesting and
david martin this was a talk where he
was talking about
life insurance companies and what we're
experiencing now
as being a life insurance illiquidity
event
and i'll have to listen to that people
there's commercials are like we will buy
your life insurance
struggling financially sell us your life
insurance reverse mortgages
are you old and gonna die we'll take
your house from your children
yeah well he was saying 30-year
mortgages when that really started
like what 30-year cycles happened in
nature he was like nothing natural
it was the life expectancy of when a
blue-collar worker
could buy a home to when he would die so
you can
pay off the bank pay off the mortgage by
the time that the bank can
foreclose on the house you know i mean
this this is pretty
you know he's going deep and he's very
hyperbolic when he's talking about these
things but
it what i like about looking at these
things and then going and skating and
hashing it out in my mind
is not all of it is bunk like some of it
it makes you
look deeper into history and be like i i
did not know that
about about the cdc do you know what
mortgage mortgage means
mortgage dead dead like a corpse
death deal death deal that's the root
word or
or if you look it up it says pledge so
death pledge yikes
yeah like why why why are we taking out
death pledges with banks
right that's weird i've even heard of
the same thing with like
um corp corporations marine corps
the way you actually spell that corp
yeah well
this was actually in one of my films on
grip that was all about
it was got into maritime admiralty law
and legalese
how the name of a lot of these things
you it sounds like you're talking
english but you're actually not these
have
alternative meanings like well uh
the latin is corporate meaning combined
in one body
body yeah so maybe maybe corp was the
body
not a dead body not a dead body okay
it'd be like mort corp or something yeah
that's the name of my my death metal
band
dead bodies mort court i like that you
brought up admiralty law i think
something
not a lot of people know about is that
there's what is it civil law and
admiralty law
there's there's a whole bunch and they
all seem to go back to ecclesiastical
law according to
my my friend who did this film and it's
an interesting thing if you are
in a certain form of law in court
according to my friend white walking
feather who
rob in the page family he said you can
pull it back to earlier forms of law and
he would always
when he was in court for not having a
driver's license and he gave up his
birth certificate and all those things
he would get pulled into court and he
would bring it back to ecclesiastical
law
where they had to recognize him as flesh
and blood rather than
a legal fiction like before the social
security cards were invented
like they've kind of corporatized law or
i don't know how to describe it exactly
but like
i'm fascinated with admiralty law that's
like the law of the sea they say like
you're birthed
when you arrive in a port and like you
you come onto the land
as a fresh you know citizen or whatever
you're a human resource
as well because that that number on the
back of your birth certificate
uh is in a human resource database
um rather than like you know some kind
of medical database
uh which makes sense you know i i see a
lot of people that they
they they draw different things from all
this
and like to me i feel like we've been
moving into this
managed you mentioned like when bill
gates was talking he said like
was he use the word management um
popular population management
that word we'll talk about more of that
in the in the after
but we can say this there's the
conspiracy theory is that bill gates
is like i'm going to kill all these
people yeah when he's actually
saying i want to make sure these people
don't exist
and that's the acceptable mainstream ted
talk
bill so bill there's this article from
reuters it's a fact checker like bill
gates did not say he wanted to wipe out
50
of the population what he said was we
want to prevent
15 of population growth right
so it's interesting that that's it's
mainstream and acceptable to be like if
the people don't exist in the first
place we're good
can somebody verify real quick because i
mean i
i watch a lot of media and sometimes i
keep an info
in the back of my head and i'm just like
i don't know but his parents bill gates
parents
anyone familiar planned parenthood i
don't know
okay i don't want to die yeah i don't
want to dive too deep into that but
the whole idea about management is what
i'm talking about with
like where we're kind of headed with
data proliferation and data aggregators
and everything is data now your medical
data is being shared
in ways that people are starting to
argue about but like where
we're heading through this entire
process that the world is going through
right now
is a lot more about management and
you'll hear people like allison mcdowell
who i
recommend everybody go check out
wrenchingthegears.com
allison mcdowell is putting together how
a lot of these dots connect and she's
saying a lot of it is poverty management
for
the coming five six seven eight years
and beyond that's what bill gates called
is poverty management poverty management
and that includes reducing population
growth
i want to mention this just real quick
like if you if you speak french you know
that mortgage means
death pledge i don't i don't quite
understand why we call it that that it's
not
horrific yeah i know like a death pledge
death pledge that's a better name for a
death metal band
best pledge or mort corp morton will be
the first album
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you